let us all now take a deep breath and
leap from here to Paris
pirates friends where we will meet one
of the glamorous stars who is herself a
nominee his best actress take it away
Paris doctor moment even even in this
jet age we can't go from Hollywood to
parents in one big leap
we must stop in New York and check
atmospheric conditions thanks to the
magic of film conditions are ideal
bringing to us a little of Paris and all
of Anastacio herself to present the
Award for Best Director miss Ingrid
Bergman Paris Jews and convenient and
recognize the location well it is very
convenient because the room for my hotel
and there is the archer prime and a
couple of rooftops for good measure and
over there is the Eiffel Tower now if
this is too convenient and too
recognizable I hope the directors will
forgive me anyway I I don't think they
are so interested in a scenery as in
tempo so for the best achievement in
direction the nominees are Michael
Anderson around the world in 80 days
William Wyler's friendly persuasion and
George Stevens the giant water Lange the
King and I and King Vito
for war and peace as for the women that
answer would have to come from the
Pantages Theatre well here we are back
at the Pantages Theatre
may I have the envelope please the
winner is giant George Stevens
as the director chosen to come up here
from this fine group of nominees let me
say for them and for myself the
director's chair is a wonderful place to
see film problems
congratulations mr. Stephens